to some subway stations in the Swedish
capital Stockholm resemble caves amateur
photographer Alexander tarakanov says
they're among the most unusual he's ever
seen and he should know he takes
pictures of the underground in cities
all over the world you can go to subway
I mean feel alone I mean hear your own
voice the air hose so it's just a
feeling of a place which I like and also
because it's empty it's quite easy to
take pictures inside so I mean you
should I mean no one disturbs you you
can do what you want you can find any
angle you want
the 35 year old photographer born in st.
Petersburg sets off in the evening when
most people have gone home subway
pictures are his passion but not his
profession during the day he works as a
programmer while photography you might
not help him pay the bills it has earned
him a cult following online many
photography enthusiasts are attracted to
his work on photo sharing platforms like
Instagram and Flickr another who gets
noticed is the london-based Miss
Underground she's got almost 35,000
followers online she takes pictures of
the London Underground with her
smartphone among the images on her page
are some snaps of the Munich underground
in southern Germany the city subway
stations are popular photographic motifs
the palatial underground stations in the
Russian capital Moscow also attract
photographers from around the world and
alexandra dragoon office work has
inspired many people to take their own
snaps of the stockholm underground
we're doing pictures of Stockholm on a
subway but we're doing it with their own
eyes with our own vision and for me it's
very interesting to look at very
pictures as well I mean to see how
someone else can see the Stockholm
subway Alexander gets out at the rotary
system
it's one of several stations whose
granite foundations have been covered in
concrete
giving the surroundings a cave-like feel
stations like these are mostly found on
the Blue Line which dates back to the
1970s Alexander says he can only capture
the perfect picture when there are no
people around and the chances of that
are best at night
still he often ends up waiting for
people to disperse and that can be quite
uncomfortable particularly when he's
squatting down
it's painful I can walk a bit wait a bit
but still I mean what I have to do is
just to pull the push your button I mean
everything is set up just waiting and
now I can do it
most of Stockholm subway stations
contain sculptures murals and art
installations the city's transport
authorities describe the underground as
the world's longest art gallery while
the artworks do feature in his
photography Laguna focuses more on lines
and symmetry he spent a year working on
his Stockholm photography project and
has compiled a book out of his best
images
it's called tunnel Bonham when it comes
to capturing the perfect image it's all
about detail in fact he's a bit of a
perfectionist
it was quite long learning curve I mean
how to make these pictures I changed a
lot of cameras I mean I changed lenses
and because finally I realized it's okay
you know to make best because you have
to use as wide lens as possible
rooster is his last stop of the night it
might not be a money-making business but
the raccoon off is proud of the large
following he's garnered online his
photographs are among the first search
results that appear when you google
Stockholm Metro for him
that's enough recognition there's some
nudie hidden underground and I mean now
people a lot of people know about it and
then we're visiting Stockholm we're not
go into some museums working on the
streets but we're also go into subway
now that he's completed his Stockholm
photography project Alexandre da Cunha
is keen to begin taking photographs in
other cities Munich and London are at
the top of his list the subway stations
there have something entirely different
to offer
you